your success is our success and the
problems we help you solve every day
make us better at what we do
thanks so much for all your support
whether I liked the most about working
at IBM cloud our clients creativity I
want to say thank you to our customers
for letting us help you be successful
with our offerings customers are the
lifeline of our business without you we
would not exist holding a diazo avail us
want to give a quick shout out to our
customers for being such creative and
innovative agents for change in the
industry which you guys are using our
tools and platform for are really
changing the world I couldn't be more
proud to be a part of it
thanks guys keep up the good work come
time you guys in my customers really
inspiring me to do the best job that I
can thank you we wouldn't be where we
are today so thank you damages me do I
just kiss the moon this is it thankfully
two wonderful clients like mine it keeps
me on my toes and really makes for a
dynamic day which are the mess can see
it doesn't supposed to each other venya
luck thank you for being patient with
IBM when we make a mistake and for
allowing us to make things right
thank you our customers and your
willingness to collaborate to drive
results are the reasons we all succeed
so thank you
yeah
[Music]
you